في ابريل عام
1992 تقدم نصر ابو زيد برسالته نقد الخطاب
الديني و بعدد اخر من مؤلفاته الى اللجنه
العلميه بجامعه القاهره للحصول على درجه
الاستاذيه في الدراسات الاسلاميه بكليه
الاداب
هو كان استاذ مساعد
ناقص ايه ناقص مجننه من خارج
الكميه بتضم ثلاثه
فكان فيها عبد الصبور شهيد
احد كتب نصر ابو زيد
في موضوع وما كانش يقصد يعني عبد الصبور
شاهين
بدقه يعني هو فكره ما يسمى
بالمقصاد الاسماعيلي وشركات توظيف الاموال
فهو قام انه
بيخدعوا المواطن البسيط باسم الدين
استاذ عبد الصبور شاهين
مستشار
قصه عبد الصبور شاهين دي انا بطل فيه انا
بطل مسلسل
برده نفس القصه كده احمد عينه مستشار عنده
في في
الشركه يعمل يعمل على اساس ان هو
ينقذوا الشركه يعني ينقذوا الشركه
[موسيقى]